الفكره كلها
ان في جامعه داما الناس كلها محور
بتاع كل
الحاجات
حاوره
شتغل
حان كت دايما يعني
عاديل اي حاجه منهم انا كنت اصلا وعندي
شويه
والحمدلله
بحب
شاء
حاجات وكده وفي شويه حاجات حتى اهل يعني
احنا
عش يعني حاجه اي كلام
يعني كت دايما
حاسه ها قد انا هاخدها في
حيات بر ح انش حاجه الحمدله
موز فحته الجواز و كان داخله لي في النص
معايا خلاص انا مسمه نفسي انا فيتجمع وبقى
ديزاينر وكده وحاجه انا بحبها وده مش
معناه ان انت يعني خماص حاجه انت بتحبها
بس
يعني يعني خلاص اكيد الواحد في الاخر
بشتغل في
حاجه
خرجت سنه 2004 وبدات فعلا ادور ان انا
اشتغل في جرافيك ديزاين ولما حسيت ان انا
دخلت شويه وبت اكلم في
الموضوع لقيت في حاجه لايه حده طبيعه
شخصيتي في حاجه مش
ماشيه
بقشط
حتي حاجه في
حاجه
ل
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
ح طعا هو بيشتغل بيعب عشاننا بس الحمد
لله في الموضوع ده وكنت اشتغل معاه في كت
حابه ان انا ابقى كده لولادي حتى وجوزي ف
قلت طب انا هشتغل مدرسه انا كنت بحب
الاطفال بحب اتعامل معاهم جدا وقلت يمكن
امشي في موضوع التدريس ده واقي نفسي في
حاجه كويسه دخلت في مدرسه انترناشنال
وبدات السنات وقعدت وانا في المدرسه
بدات كنت بعمل
المدرسه فكره كده
عم
بقى محجبات
بالات
يعني حاجات
معينه حاجات
كويسه يعني يجيب ناس كويسه ويجيب ناس
كتيره وهو اصلا مجود في البيت في الاخر
فكانت حتى في الاخر يعني الناس اللي بتيجي
نفسها ود كونكشن الحمدلله
يعنيلي وعندي صحاب كتير قوي وعندي ع كتير
قوي اهلي و اصحابي في الجامعه فكان في ناس
كتير منها بتيجي الجامد بس اللي جه جامد
ده ج اتبسط فجاب صحابه ككس تايم وبقى
الموضوع بدا يبقى اكبر شويه وبدات الناس
في تراست ليست اللي انا هجيبه بقى في
تراست للحاجات اللي انا ف حد سجست كده ده
وانا بشتغل في المدرسه انا فاتحه اوبشنز
كتير قدامي يعني انا حبيت قوي لما مست
توهامي كلم وقال ان انت يعني لازم تبقي
اوكي خليكي في ان انت
يعني مافيش مشكله بس اوبن ي سف في حاجه
انا ممكن اكون بحبها بحب ديزاين بس انا
بطبيعه
شخصيتي مالقتش نفسي فيها مش لقي في حاجه
يعني انا كنت بصحى الصبح المدرسه ومع زين
انا بشتغل على الض في حاجه مضيقي صح
المدرسه انا ببص المنب زي ما كان برض كريم
ققول انا
بصح شغل ده ليه بس انا لازم
اشتغل مش حبيت بس انا مش
شايفه مش
لازم في الاخر حاجه جي سال يعني انت بتحسي
ان انت في ناس قولت ما انت هتيجي على
اولادك هتيجي لا انا لو كنت ما اشتغلتش
وقعدت جنب ولادي فول تايم جنبهم كنت هقصر
معاهم قوي ان انا كنت هبقى دايما حاسه ان
هم كانوا بيردن عليا ان انا ما اشتغلش كان
عاقد ان انا ماشوفش حاجه انا بحبها وعايزه
اعملها فكنت حاسه ان انا اني هطلعها عليه
يعني بص بقى يعني ايه ابعد عني دلوقتي ما
اشتغلتش بو انا اقعد اط نار بزعق بعمل لا
دلوقتي انا حاسه
اشتغلت في نفس
الوقت
حسسني نظر حاجه كو
حاحه فيها
حتنا احسله نفها حاجه كده محترمينك فيها
تريحي تلكي انت نفسك على
طول حتى جو
بيتك دايما حاسه ان لازم اشتغل الشغل حتى
المدرسه وانا هناك فبدات شويه ناس قالتلي
طب ايه او بقوللك ايه ده في دلوقتي ناس
كتير في كم حد كده يعملوا
وبتاع ليه ماتروحيش تقولي يعني تروحيش
تعملي حاجه اكبر شويه
وتبداي تجيبي ناس وناس انت شايفه ان هم
عندهم كده يع بدات فعلا افكر في فكره
اقول
بتجيلي ميا حاجتك حلوه قوي هو انت ليه مش
عامله لنفسك ليه مش عامله لنفسك دي مش م
لا معرفش فين هعمل ايه طب يعني انت شايفه
ان انا ممكن اعمل ايه بصي يعني دايما
كان ز وبجد يعني
حده عمل شويه
حاجات في
ناانا حسيت لما
ب
حاجه
كده ف الحمدلله بدات قبل حت
اضع
كيرال فلما راح فعلا بدات ان برض الناس
بتجيلي بتجيلي حده انا جايب حاجات من بره
بص في الاخ في ناس
تقول
هي صاحبه يعني هي في ست مثلا انا بسافر ب
بتعب وبجيب حاجات حلوه قوي عشان الناس
تشتريها مت و في نفس الوقت انا بكسب منها
نفسي بيساعدني في بيتي مع جوزي فان
بتبصلها بس في نفس الوقت بفتح شويه مجال
صغيرنا اللي
هي هم يعرفوا يجيبوا حاجات وبيجيبوا حاجات
مطلوبه يعني حاجات عليها
جما بيعوا كي قوي نعم مش شغلين ايديهم بس
حاجات انت عايزاها انت هتشتريها وانت
تتعجبي بيه وفي نفس الوقت برض يعني تفرق
معايا قوي عامله ايه طب الحاجه اللي انت
عاملاها دي موجود فيها منكت طب انت عامله
حاجه جديده يعني طب حاجتك
طبالي فكنت كل شويه ان انا برض بركز قوي
في
حته يعني مش عايزه اطول عليكم في الحته
قوي بتاع الموضوع ج ازاي بس الحمد لله س
يعني سون كده بدات عملنا اول ايفنتس في
الايفنت انا عملت الايفنت ده ورك لوجو
وانا في المدرسه وانا في المدرسه في البيت
بتاع المدرسه كنتش مقصره خالص في المدرسه
ك خصها شغلي فانا يعني بدور على حااجه
وانا بعمل والحمد لله لما لقيت الموضوع
انا مشش فيه كويس ومبسوطه بيه كلمت معاهم
وقلت لهم ان دي اخر سنه ليه معاكم وانا
استفدت منكم حاجات انيه كتير قوي في حياتي
بس انا شايفه نفسي اكتر في المجال ده
وبدات اور المجال ده بس انا مبسوطه قوي
فيه لان انا مقنعه حاجه ان ان انا يعني
على قد ما انا مقتنعه المفروض ان البنت
تشتغل عامه بس في نفس
الوقت فشن في حاجه برض ان شاء الله فشن
فيها مش لازم يكون انا طالع الفاشن
بتاعي ار حاجات التقليديه يعني ان انا كنت
دايما مستنيه اخد من الجامعه اشتغل في
شركه
اطلع اسست طلع هطلع عشان المك يعني بقى ان
في وفي هندسه وكده فلقيت م تب حاجه صغيره
قي شاطره وتعمليها اصلا في حياتك ما تخيش
ان هي في يوم الام هتب هيدي شغ الاصلاب هي
دي والحمد لله تبقى يعني طبعا
دايما
ق لازم
دايما بتاعتك اوه ايه وابداي بقى
اشتغلي انا دايما شغلي بص قوي
يعني فلان انا بش يعني بحب اشتغل مع نفسي
لازم تشتغلي حجه اشتغلي مع نفسك مع الناس
ما تشتغلي بدك في حاجه بتحبيها وتحسي ان
انت مبسوطه بيه حتى الناس
في
يعني حتى مع اقل عن بشتغل معاك حته ان انت
اصلا تبقى ي انا ب بشيل على الترابيزه
بشيل انا الكتع ج وال في ايفنت عملته سنت
تاني يومست ق كان كل الناس بش حاجه وان
حام حت يعني ف كان دايما دي حاجه بتدي حتى
كبتي للناس ان ايه ده هو انت يعني بتحبي
مش بس انا بحب شغلي بس هي ماينفعش تعدي
على كتي وتشاوري بايدك بس حت دي ع انا بحس
ان هي وبتدي حت في الشغل يعني وفرقت معايا
قوي في التيم وورك بتاعنا الحمد لله ويت
دخل معايا بارتنر رنا يعني انا انبسطت قوي
انها دخلت معايا لرون وكانت فعلا اديشن ل
بازارنا جامد قوي بس ودايما كان جوزي
يخوفني يقوللي اوعي ت شريك شغل شريك بوصي
شغل خلاص كده لا يعني لا مش شرط مش شرط
خالص الحمد لله يعني في في الاول تعش
معينه هتحصل بس هي ولاقي ان
انتجات بعض منفر الموضوع علسكم تشتغلوا
فيه و هقول كده الحاجات اللي انا استتها
في شغلي ح ان انا وصلها له وا ان اناه لان
انا كنت احب ان انا في يوم من الايام اسمع
الحاجات دي وانا في الجامعه بالذ ده اللي
خدي ده اللي خلاني اد انها وانها
جامعه
[موسيقى]
الحمدله احنا عندنا مشكله في مصر
دلوقتي عندنا مشكله في مصر دلوقتي
هيده حاجه اسبوع واحد
ما فيش مشكله على فكره معس في ناس بتعمل
بس اي
يعني كف ان انا انتوا عملتوا ايه بجد حلو
قوي بس انا مش عمل اوي يعني انا انا هعمل
حاجه انت هي بجد تحفه يعني بس انا هدور
على حاجه جديده ان شاء الله هطلع بايديا
جديده هقدمها في الافن ده فبقت الناس
بتيجي الا انت عامله ايه مرا دي اص احنا
هنشوف حاجه المهاش كده الديزاين بقيت
اتكلم معاه لما تجيلنا واحده عامله حاجات
بالظبط زي واحده انا
اس ما ينفعش عشان انت في الاخر
يعني احنا لازم نتعلم ان احنا في شغلنا اص
لو انت بدات تغ ان انت
ك
هتنجح مافيش مشكله بس هتيجي تص يعني في
حاجه غلط ايه ده طب دلوقتي هعمل ايه ماتيش
نفسك تتفكري ماتيش نفسك ان انت تطلعي ال
الجديده تنجحي بها ففي الاخر ض
هعمل ايه بس عطع بالتي اللي زيها في حاجه
غلط
وقعش فعشان كده انت لازم تبقى حاجه حها بس
يلا ك يلا
يلايلا يلا لا وده الحمد لله حاجه ثبتنا
قوي في
[تصفيق]
بتاعتنا وانا بقى اول واحدهه ان تب
بتاعك حاولي دايما ان
[موسيقى]
انت عمري في حياتي
ك عمري في
حياتي الحمدلله يكون عشان كان عارفه ان
عندي يعني مع انش
بر زي ققول عندك بديل بس انا لا كنت دايما
حاس ان
مابقاش زم
الاول
بعد بس ماينفعش
هدش هو هدفي وان عمل كطلع من مش اناكسبت
كام كويس قوليلي كويس ايه الع
قي
قل مع
مع هم
كانله الناس كمان انتجي سبب ان واحده ست
جاك تقوللك س وايف انا عندي اولاد انا
معتمده على الزار بتاعي وبستناه عشان انا
فيه بش ح شهور قدام
لا دي كانت حاجه حني الموضوع مش بس ان انا
بجيب شويه ناس
لا هم كمان سكس وانا السكسس ده يعني فرق
معايا قوي في حياتي فرق معايا قوي ان انا
يعني حاس ان انا عندي صفه كويسه جدا وس
اهلي وس اولادي ومبسوطه جدا ان انا بصلت ل
صغير يعني ان بتاعك اصلا وابراهيم ق حاجه
عجبتني جدا حته ان انت دايما يبقى عندك ين
ان ربنا يحكمك ده انا فعلا دخلت في امور
كتيره قوي انا مبسوط
خسرت فيها ومبسوطه ان غلطت فيها لان هي
علمتني هي خلتني اعمل الاحس ما كنتش دخلت
وفسرت وتعلمت في المواقف دي بنسها وتحط في
اسوا مواقف وتحط خص من مشاكل مع الناس
كلها انا ماهاش ان انا اقدامها وازي عملت
كده ولا لا انا حطيتها نوت نفس التز نفس
البن يعني
ايه
ان
اه بس عا
حاولتم انا عايز
اقول بس انا بحول حاجه اه بحب
انشوف نفس الحاجات شوفي عايز ايه عايز
عايز مش عارفه ايه طب ال جبتنا بس احنا
بقى ان احنا نقدم حاجات جديده بس والحمد
لله انا مبسطه قوي سبب ان انا ناجحه وفي
نفس الوقت سبب ان انا ان هم يبين ولحد
النهارده يعني في ناس كتير بدس من شغلنا
ودس منه وخد في ناس بتعل عن
حاجات وا ان شاء الله ان انا
اشوف ان شاء
[تصفيق]
الله
r